Just before we dive into today's episode, I wanted to let you know that I'm running a free 5-day challenge, which starts on Monday the 12th of May. You are so warmly invited to join us. It's designed to help you build your confidence, gain clarity and take practical steps forward in your psychology career journey. Whether you're applying for assistant psychologist roles, for the doctorate in clinical psychology, or just feeling a bit stuck. Each day there will be a short live training with me, just 15 to 20 minutes, plus a simple task
在进入今天的节目之前，我想告诉大家，我正在举办一个为期5天的免费挑战活动，将于5月12日星期一正式开始。非常诚挚地邀请大家加入我们。这个活动旨在帮助你建立自信、理清思路，并在心理学职业道路上迈出切实的一步。无论你是在申请助理心理学家职位、临床心理学博士学位，还是仅仅感到有些迷茫，都可以参加。每天我都会进行15到20分钟的简短直播培训，并布置一个简单的任务，
to help you move forward with more purpose and support. You can grab your complimentary space now via the link in the show notes, or on any of my social media links too. There's a link in the bio. I can't wait to see you there on the 12th of May. What does an occupational or organisational psychologist do and why is proactivity such an important psychological skill to nurture. In this episode, I am joined once again
帮助你更有目标、更有支持地向前迈进。你现在可以通过节目说明中的链接，或者我社交媒体上的任何链接来获取你的免费名额。个人简介里也有链接。我迫不及待地想在5月12日见到大家。职业心理学家或组织心理学家是做什么的？为什么主动性是职场中如此重要的心理技能？在这一集中，我再次邀请到了
by Dr. Jo Gray, who is an organisational psychologist. We explore how psychologists can facilitate meaningful change in workplaces and why proactivity, not just in ourselves, but in teams and systems is key to long-term success and wellbeing at work. If you're curious about different branches in psychology or you want to understand how to support growth and change in organisations, this one's for you.
组织心理学家乔·格雷（Dr. Jo Gray）博士。我们将探讨心理学家如何促进工作场所的有意义变革，以及为什么主动性——不仅是我们自身，还有团队和系统中的主动性——是职场长期成功和幸福感的关键。如果你对心理学的不同分支感到好奇，或者想了解如何支持组织的发展与变革，那么这一集非常适合你。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. It's so lovely to have you here. And we are welcoming back a previous guest today because the content has been really helpful and people have been reaching out to Joe and to myself. So with no further ado, let's dive in and say hello again to Joe.
大家好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。很高兴你能来到这里。今天我们再次欢迎一位之前的嘉宾，因为之前的内容非常有帮助，很多人都联系了乔和我。那么，废话不多说，让我们开始吧，再次向乔问好。
Hi, I just want to welcome back a lovely face who's been with us before. It's Dr. Jo Gray. Welcome back, Jo. Thank you. So lovely to see you and be here. It really is lovely to see you. And I've invited you back
嗨，我想欢迎一位我们之前见过的可爱面孔回归。她就是乔·格雷博士。欢迎回来，乔。谢谢。很高兴见到你，也很高兴来到这里。见到你真的很高兴。我邀请你回来
because there's been quite the appetite for occupational and organisational psychology since we first met. When we met, you were just coming to the end of your training. You are now qualified. Congratulations. Thank you. Thank you. It already feels like a long time ago but yes it wasn't that long ago. Yeah like life moves very quickly doesn't it? So if people want to know more about you and how we know
是因为自从我们第一次见面以来，人们对职业心理学和组织心理学的兴趣非常浓厚。我们见面时，你刚结束培训。现在你已经获得资格了。恭喜你。谢谢。谢谢。感觉好像是很久以前的事了，但其实没过多久。是的，生活节奏很快，不是吗？所以如果人们想更多地了解你，以及我们如何
what the field of organizational occupational psychology is and your experiences they should definitely check out the previous episode, which will be linked in the show notes and in the description. But today is going to be a little bit different because I'm going to kind of hand over the reins to our expert organizational psychologist to set the context and to kind of talk us through what this episode's going to be like. So over to you, Jo. Yeah, well thank you and thanks for the opportunity to come back and also a privilege to see your lovely face again. So, and I thought obviously after having some discussions with you and having had some of your listeners and viewers reach out to me following the last episode. It does seem like there's an appetite to understand a little bit more about what organizational or occupational psychologists do. They are one in the same thing. It's linked to whether you're registered with the BPS or not.
了解组织职业心理学领域，了解你的经历，他们一定要去看看上一集，链接会在节目说明和描述中提供。但今天会有点不同，因为我要把指挥棒交给我们的专家组织心理学家，由她来设定背景，并为我们介绍这一集的内容。那么，交给你了，乔。好的，谢谢你，也感谢你给我机会回来，能再次见到你这张可爱的脸也是我的荣幸。显然，在和你进行了一些讨论，并且在上一集之后收到了一些听众和观众的反馈后，我发现大家确实有兴趣进一步了解组织心理学家或职业心理学家是做什么的。它们其实是一回事。这取决于你是否在英国心理学会（BPS）注册。
So I will kind of interchange. I'll use organizational psychologists for the purposes of today. And what I thought would be helpful is maybe just outline, just like as a clinical psychologist, you have an approach to the way you work. I thought it might be helpful to kick off maybe just highlighting.
所以我可能会交替使用这两个词。为了今天的讨论，我将使用“组织心理学家”这个称呼。我觉得有必要先概述一下，就像作为临床心理学家，你有一套工作方法一样，我想先强调一下。
There's a lot of terminology around evidence-based practitioners. And I think it's a little bit of a buzzword that maybe would be helpful for people to understand a little bit more about what that means in the context of work psychology, psychology at work. So I thought I could talk to you about that. And then I thought we could maybe talk about some scenarios that might crop up the kinds
关于“循证从业者”有很多术语。我认为这是一个有点流行的词，如果人们能更多地了解它在工作心理学、职场心理学背景下的含义，会有所帮助。所以我想和你谈谈这个。然后我想我们可以谈谈可能出现的一些场景，
of work that I have been involved in or get involved in or some of my colleagues get involved in just to highlight some of the tools my colleagues get involved in, just to highlight some of the tools and the processes that we would tend to draw on if that's helpful and then I would like the opportunity to tell you a little bit about my upcoming book. Oh that sounds all amazing and it is not brand new information because as you said we've already discussed this but I love that and I love that you've come with such enthusiasm for this. So we have already had a think about kind of some case studies and we will come on to those, but please do go ahead. Yeah, I thought, as I said, I thought before we got
我参与过或正在参与的工作，或者我的一些同事参与的工作，以此来强调我们倾向于使用的工具和流程。如果这有帮助的话，之后我想借此机会向你介绍一下我即将出版的新书。哦，听起来太棒了。虽然这不是全新的信息，因为正如你所说，我们已经讨论过了，但我很喜欢这个想法，也很欣赏你带来的热情。我们已经考虑了一些案例研究，稍后会讲到，但请继续。好的，正如我所说，我想在进入
into scenarios, it would be helpful just to kind of set out some of the basic principles, because I think there is also this kind of, yeah, organizational circle, occupational circle, what even is that? An evidence-based practitioner. So I thought it'd be helpful because I would describe myself as an evidence-based practitioner and consultant. So what does that even mean? And it really is about how we approach our work. And when it comes to client work, so we'll talk about these scenarios in a minute, but when a client comes with something they want help with, then I would tend to use what we call the consultancy cycle.
场景之前，先列出一些基本原则，因为我觉得大家对“组织心理学”、“职业心理学”这些圈子，甚至“循证从业者”到底是什么，还存在一些困惑。所以我想解释一下，因为我会称自己为循证从业者和顾问。这到底意味着什么？这实际上关乎我们如何开展工作。当涉及到客户工作时——我们稍后会讨论这些场景——当客户带着他们需要帮助的问题来找我时，我倾向于使用我们所说的“咨询周期”。
And that essentially involves starting off, having the conversation, trying to understand what their needs are and doing what we call contracting, setting some expectations about what's within our gift or scope of influence, what we can do, some of the really basic things as an independent practitioner, you know, how much you charge, how long do things take, the kind of processes involved. So it's, I mean, it is the contracting piece. So you set off with a relationship that's there's no room for ambiguity,
这本质上包括从开始对话、试图了解他们的需求，到进行我们所说的“签约”，即设定一些关于我们能力或影响范围内的期望，我们能做什么，以及作为独立从业者的一些非常基础的事情，比如你收费多少、事情需要多长时间、涉及什么样的流程。所以，这就是签约环节。这样你开始一段关系时，就不会有任何歧义，
which is really important, right? That's the kind of first stage. Then once we've agreed there's work to do together, we get into what we call the information gathering stage. And that's where, when you hear about evidence-based practice, this is that we're gathering information from multiple sources. So if you're my client and you come to me with a problem,
这非常重要，对吧？这是第一阶段。一旦我们商定要一起工作，我们就进入所谓的“信息收集阶段”。这就是当你听到“循证实践”时所指的——我们从多个来源收集信息。所以，如果你是我的客户，带着问题来找我，
I'm not going to just take your word for that, sorry. I'm going to want to do a little bit more digging around. Want to come in, maybe make some observations. And again, I know you do that in a clinical sense, you know, you work with a client, but you're going to want to gather context. Also draw on personal experience, which I have quite a bit of. Also looking at the academic literature, which can be really helpful, but we need to know sometimes that has its limitations, depending on what the setting of the study was, you know,
抱歉，我不会只听你的一面之词。我会想做更多的挖掘。我想进去看看，也许做一些观察。同样，我知道你在临床意义上也会这样做，你与客户合作，但你会想要收集背景信息。还要利用个人经验，我在这方面有不少积累。还要查看学术文献，这真的很有帮助，但我们需要知道，有时它有局限性，取决于研究的背景，你知道，
we need to be careful about saying research says, but actually, if there's several studies in the same setting that you find yourself in, then you can start to say, oh, okay, there's some, there's some evidence here, there's some interventions here, there's some theories here that could be relevant. And so with all of that information, you're then in a position to start making some plans, recommendations, so you formulate, get the client sign off,
我们需要谨慎对待“研究表明”这种说法。但实际上，如果你所在的领域有几项研究都指向同一个结论，那么你就可以开始说，哦，好的，这里有一些证据、一些干预措施、一些理论可能是有意义的。有了所有这些信息，你就可以开始制定计划、提出建议，进行方案制定，获得客户的认可，
and then obviously start to deliver those and importantly reflect on it as you're going through, report on it, and then do a thorough evaluation to show that this was worth doing. It worked. People want to see a return on investment. So that's what we describe is the consultancy cycle. Does that make sense? It does and it sounds exciting and because I'm excited about lots of things, I'm like, oh yes, I'd like to do that. And I know that that is a nice trait, but also can be problematic in organisations as well. And we might well cover that later too. But yes, it sounds amazing, Jo, thank you.
然后显然开始实施这些方案，重要的是在过程中进行反思、报告，然后进行彻底的评估，以证明这样做是值得的。它奏效了。人们希望看到投资回报。这就是我们所说的咨询周期。这有道理吗？很有道理，听起来很令人兴奋。因为我对很多事情都感到兴奋，我会想，哦，是的，我想那样做。我知道这是一个很好的特质，但在组织中也可能成为问题。我们稍后可能会谈到这一点。但是的，听起来太棒了，乔，谢谢你。
And it is. It's a rigorous approach. And sometimes people might want to cut corners. I would say, you know, it's a proven sort of structure that works well. I'll just quickly delve into this information gathering piece, because this is when you can also then start drawing on other frameworks. I've previously used this approach that we call design thinking to organisational interventions. Again, it's your thinking in different stages.
确实如此。这是一种严谨的方法。有时人们可能想走捷径。我会说，这是一种行之有效的结构。我将快速深入探讨这个信息收集环节，因为这时你也可以开始利用其他框架。我之前在组织干预中使用了这种被称为“设计思维”的方法。同样，这是在不同阶段进行思考。
I've got my own take on this. So design thinking is all about, you know, understand what the problem is, figuring out what your options are with the evidence you've got and then creating plans and launching them. So I've created my own version of that called the Progress Formula,
我有自己的看法。设计思维就是了解问题所在，利用你现有的证据找出你的选择，然后制定计划并启动它们。所以我创建了自己的版本，称为“进步公式”（Progress Formula），
because my consultancy is called the Progress Lab, although I do a lot of work within proactive behavior, but and I call it the progress formula and it's five P's and it's about probing, probing the problem, problem identification, processing the possibilities, creating purposeful plans, propagating. So you know, getting them out there by bringing people on board. So participating within, you know, getting participation, and by bringing people on board. So participating with them, you know, getting participation and then proofing is the evaluation.
因为我的咨询公司叫“进步实验室”（Progress Lab），尽管我在主动行为方面做了很多工作。我称之为“进步公式”，它由五个P组成：探究（Probing）问题、识别问题（Problem identification）、处理（Processing）可能性、创建有目的的计划（Purposeful plans）、传播（Propagating）。所以，通过让人们参与进来来推广它们。所以，参与其中，通过让人们加入。所以，与他们一起参与，你知道，获得参与，然后证明（Proofing）就是评估。
So that's all the kind of technical jargon out of the way but I think that just gives you a sense of, I guess, why working with a qualified occupational psychologist, organizational psychologist might give you a slightly different experience to someone who's maybe not got that training and background. Absolutely. And this is why it's really important to work with people with the appropriate qualifications. I understand that you are not registered with the HCPC because you didn't do a psychology undergrad, but you are still, you still have the professional qualifications. And so I think for me, that's a bit of a learning point as well, is that people might be having the right qualification, but they might, they may be good and important reasons why they're not registered
所以，这就是所有的技术术语。但我认为这让你感觉到，为什么与合格的职业心理学家、组织心理学家合作，可能会给你带来与那些没有受过这种培训和背景的人完全不同的体验。绝对是这样。这就是为什么与具备适当资格的人合作非常重要。我知道你没有在英国健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）注册，因为你没有心理学本科学位，但你仍然拥有专业资格。所以对我来说，这也是一个学习点，即人们可能拥有正确的资格，但他们没有在HCPC注册可能有很好且重要的原因。
with the HCPC. So I've learned something there too, Jo. There you go. There you go. So our first case study is looking at supporting employees during organisational change. So the context for that, a large financial services organisation is undergoing a major restructure due to a merger. The company is consolidating departments, leading to role changes, job uncertainty and potential layoffs.
乔，我也学到了这一点。那么我们的第一个案例研究是关于在组织变革期间支持员工。背景是：一家大型金融服务机构因合并正在进行重大重组。公司正在整合部门，导致角色变动、工作不确定性和潜在的裁员。
Employees are anxious about their future and HR is concerned about a decline in morale and performance. So let's take a look at the challenges here. There's discomfort around the change. Employees exhibit low engagement and cooperation, delaying the implementation of new processes. Communication issues, a lack of transparent communication leads to rumors and misinformation. And lastly trust perceptions, uncertainty makes employees hesitant to share ideas or collaborate effectively. Alright so that's our first little case study or vignette and I think these can be really
员工对未来感到焦虑，人力资源部门担心士气和绩效下降。让我们看看这里的挑战。对变革感到不安。员工表现出低参与度和配合度，延误了新流程的实施。沟通问题，缺乏透明的沟通导致谣言和错误信息。最后是信任感知，不确定性使员工在分享想法或有效协作方面犹豫不决。好的，这是我们的第一个小案例研究或片段，我认为这些可以非常
helpful approaches to really help people get an understanding of what work would an occupational organization or psychologist do? Could you give us a brief overview of what you would do in this example? Yeah and I like this example for several reasons. One, it happens fairly frequently, lots of organisations, particularly in the current sign of economic socio-political context as organisations merge, they have for a long time. And I've worked in organisations when I worked almost 20 years in corporate roles and experienced the merge situation several times. So I've got that first-hand experience, not altogether positive, if I'm honest.
有帮助，能真正帮助人们了解职业心理学家或组织心理学家会做什么工作。你能简要概述一下在这个例子中你会做什么吗？是的，我喜欢这个例子，原因有几个。第一，这种情况发生得相当频繁，很多组织，特别是在当前的经济和社会政治背景下，随着组织合并，这种情况已经持续了很长时间。我曾在企业角色中工作了近20年，多次经历过合并的情况。所以我有一手经验，说实话，并不全是积极的。
So that was one of, you know, I'm always motivated by how you can do things differently. So I've got that first-hand experience and it is really difficult for employees. And when I talk employees, I'm talking everybody, really difficult for everybody. And for managers, for leaders, everybody in the organization, it can be really difficult. I've worked with various scenarios like this, and it kind of depends what's needed at the time. But there's various things that you might get involved with. So, I mean, a strategic level, if I was brought in at a strategic level, if we're really still trying to figure out what these changes meant for the sort of the organisational design, then we might get involved at that level. And that might be, you know, again, looking at the
所以，我总是被如何以不同的方式做事所激励。我有第一手经验，这对员工来说真的很困难。当我谈到员工时，我指的是所有人，对每个人来说都非常困难。对于经理、领导者，组织中的每个人，这都可能非常困难。我处理过各种这样的场景，这取决于当时需要什么。但你可能会参与各种各样的事情。所以，我的意思是，在战略层面，如果我被引入战略层面，如果我们要真正弄清楚这些变化对组织设计意味着什么，那么我们可能会参与到那个层面。这可能意味着，再次强调，查看
evidence around change, change management, organisational design, and job design. So in previous work that I've done, I have looked at different frameworks. There's actually probably not surprising to you, there is so many different frameworks on what good organisational change should look like. Yet, interestingly, some really outdated frameworks are still being used. This is one of the frustrations sometimes in our work that there's almost that face validity of some frameworks, even though we're kind of like that was developed in the 80s and 90s and things have changed. So there's quite a lot of change frameworks out there that get used often but actually aren't in my opinion the best.
关于变革、变革管理、组织设计和工作设计的证据。在我之前的工作中，我研究过不同的框架。实际上，对你来说可能并不奇怪，关于好的组织变革应该是什么样子，有太多不同的框架了。然而，有趣的是，一些非常过时的框架仍然在使用。这是我们工作中偶尔会感到沮丧的一点，即某些框架虽然我们觉得那是80年代和90年代开发的，而且情况已经发生了变化，但它们似乎仍然具有“表面效度”。所以有很多变革框架经常被使用，但在我看来并不是最好的。
And I actually did a project when I was going through my professional doctorate where I did a project that involved a change and I actually did a little light touch review of all the different change frameworks and almost tried to do, tried to get to taking the best from to come up with something really good. So I do have a little adapted version and process for how you therefore help an organization go through some of the change. Communication tends to be one of the biggest issues in organizations when they're going through change, whether it's the what they're communicating, how they're communicating, the frequency in which they're communicating or not. So communication tends to be something that we might get involved in helping the senior team communicate the vision and be able to bring people on with them.
我在攻读专业博士学位时做过一个项目，涉及到一个变革，我实际上对所有不同的变革框架做了一个轻量级的回顾，并试图从中汲取精华，想出一个真正好的方案。所以我确实有一个小的适应版本和流程，用来帮助组织经历一些变革。当组织经历变革时，沟通往往是最大的问题之一，无论是他们沟通的内容、沟通的方式，还是他们沟通的频率。所以沟通往往是我们可能参与的事情，帮助高级团队传达愿景，并能够带领人们一起前进。
I've also done work previously where actually if the organisation's looking for employees to actually participate in giving their perspectives on things, I'd really advocate. So, you know, running focus groups, trying to do some kind of appreciative inquiry, what is good about, you know, what's currently here, what would you absolutely want to keep in a new version of this organisation? So actually conducting some qualitative research, getting that participation, that helps people with what we call change readiness. So you're bringing people on the journey rather than coming from the top here,
我之前也做过工作，如果组织正在寻找员工来真正参与并提供他们的观点，我会非常提倡。所以，运行焦点小组，尝试进行某种欣赏式探究，什么是好的，当前这里有什么，在组织的新版本中你绝对想保留什么？所以实际上进行一些定性研究，获得那种参与，这有助于人们实现我们所说的“变革准备”。所以你是带着人们一起踏上旅程，而不是从上面下来，
this is what we're doing and everyone goes, why would you do that? Doesn't make sense. So trying to combine that kind of bottom up and top down approach to change. Yeah, that sounds really good. And it's kind of forefront in my mind anyway today, because when I was eating my lunch, we're recording on the day where the news broke that WH Smith is going to be only focusing on its travel and airport shops. It's going to be disappearing
这是我们正在做的，每个人都会问，你为什么要那样做？这说不通。所以试图结合那种自下而上和自上而下的变革方法。是的，这听起来真的很棒。而且今天它在我脑海中占据了前沿位置，因为我在吃午饭时，我们录制的这一天新闻爆出，WH Smith将只专注于其旅游和机场商店。它将从商业街消失，
from the high street and it's being bought out by someone else. And so as you were speaking, I was thinking, well, this is going to happen to so many people across the UK that are currently working for WH Smith and presumably will be two-ped into this new organization. But actually, the WH Smith brand has been on the high street for over 200 years. It's very, it's very, you know, embedded in UK culture. And, you know, that that will run through the organisation. And they made it clear to say that actually, the shops are still doing well. It's just that they really want to see themselves pivoting to be a travel retail brand, which is not the same kind of as as on high street presence is it? Yeah and you know I guess they're evolving to the needs of the consumer
并被其他人收购。所以当你说话时，我在想，这对英国目前在WH Smith工作的许多人来说都会发生，他们大概会被并入这个新组织。但实际上，WH Smith品牌在商业街上已经存在了200多年。它非常深入地植根于英国文化。而且，你知道，这会贯穿整个组织。他们明确表示，实际上，商店仍然做得很好。只是他们真的希望将自己转型为旅游零售品牌，这与商业街的存在感是不一样的，对吧？是的，我想他们正在根据消费者的需求进行演变，
and to the stakeholders to a certain degree so and some of these changes can be difficult for people to process so one of the other things that I do a lot actually is organizations going through significant changes is more of a kind of learning and development type initiative. So whether that be helping at an individual level, build some resilience, build some coping strategies for navigating change, because change is tricky, right? You know, even I'm someone who really leans into it. But some things, you know, particularly if you really enjoy your job and the way things are structured, and the colleagues, you know, that feels like a loss, if that's going to change. You know, it can create a real, you know, emotional response, and it's
并在一定程度上满足利益相关者的需求。所以其中一些变化对人们来说可能很难处理。因此，我做的另一件事，实际上是在组织经历重大变革时，更多的是一种学习和发展类型的倡议。无论是帮助个人层面，建立一些韧性，建立一些应对变革的应对策略，因为变革很棘手，对吧？你知道，即使是我这样的人，也非常倾向于它。但有些事情，特别是如果你真的很喜欢你的工作和事情的结构方式，以及同事，你知道，如果这些要改变，那感觉就像是一种损失。你知道，它会产生一种真实的、你知道，情感反应，而且对人们来说
difficult for people. So we do a lot of work at that individual level, but also helping leaders and managers be able to support their teams in navigating some of those changes is really important. And actually, I mean, one thing I always say when I'm working with leaders and managers is you've also got to put your own oxygen mask on first because you are also going through this change and you're supporting others. You're trying to be the best manager you can be. You're soaking up some of that emotional contagion and you're trying to remain positive and motivated and driven when you yourself are experiencing some of those feelings. So it can be a really tricky time. But there are again lots of things, lots of strategies that we can encourage people to think about and work out what's going to what the primary emotions are when we see a secondary
很困难。所以我们在个人层面做了很多工作，但帮助领导者和经理能够支持他们的团队应对其中一些变化也非常重要。实际上，我的意思是，当我和领导者和经理一起工作时，我总是说的一件事是，你必须先戴上你自己的氧气面罩，因为你也在经历这种变化，而且你还在支持他人。你正在努力成为你能成为的最好的经理。你正在吸收一些那种情绪传染，并且当你自己也在经历其中一些感受时，你正在努力保持积极、有动力和干劲。所以这可能是一个非常棘手的时期。但同样有很多事情，很多策略我们可以鼓励人们去思考，并找出当我们在看到次要
activity like anger or kind of fear, you know, there'll be a very good and important reason that probably comes first. And it seems like what you do as an occupational, organizational psychologist is, is to kind of support everybody so that it feels less us versus them and kind of we're in it together. it together and we're trying to find a way that the honours and respects everybody in this organisation, not just those at the top. Yeah, yeah for sure. And I think that's what a lot of the work I would do reminds the senior leaders and decision makers that actually if you want to create a culture of change, you need to bring people
情绪（如愤怒或恐惧）时，主要的潜在情绪是什么。你知道，这背后可能有一个非常好的、重要的原因。看起来你作为一名职业、组织心理学家所做的事情，就是支持每个人，让它感觉不那么像“我们对他们”，而是“我们在一起”。在一起，我们正在努力寻找一种尊重组织中每个人的方式，而不仅仅是那些高层的人。是的，当然。我认为这就是我所做的很多工作，提醒高级领导者和决策者，实际上，如果你想创造一种变革文化，你需要带人们
on the journey with you. People do not like feeling done to. Yeah, and that's where then this whole participation and, you know, involving, you know, whether it's focus groups, improvement groups, getting people and listening to them, and being honest about what you can respond to and being honest about what you can and fulfilling that. So again, communication comes back. It's at the heart of it. And I always say when the communication breaks down, unfortunately, you've got to have a problem. Yeah. Yeah. I love that. Thank you, Jo. Let's go on to our second case study. Our second one is addressing issues around employee burnout.
一起踏上旅程。人们不喜欢被“强加”的感觉。是的，这就是为什么参与，以及涉及，你知道，无论是焦点小组、改进小组，让人们参与并倾听他们的意见，并对你能回应的事情保持诚实，对你能做到的事情保持诚实并履行承诺。所以，沟通又回来了。它是核心。我总是说，当沟通中断时，不幸的是，你就会遇到问题。是的。是的。我喜欢这一点。谢谢你，乔。让我们进入我们的第二个案例研究。我们的第二个案例是解决员工倦怠问题。
The context is an HR professional in a pharmaceutical company notices a significant rise in absenteeism and turnover among employees in operations. Employee Assistance Programme, EAP, data reveals an increase in stress related claims. Employees report feeling overwhelmed, emotionally drained and disengaged. Our challenges are reduced productivity, staff are mentally and physically exhausted, affecting their performance. Increased turnover, this is driving higher attrition, putting additional strain on remaining employees and low morale. Employees feel undervalued and unsupported, creating a negative workplace atmosphere. Okay, so what are you doing in that case?
背景是：一家制药公司的人力资源专业人士注意到运营部门员工的缺勤率和离职率显著上升。员工援助计划（EAP）数据显示，与压力相关的索赔有所增加。员工报告感到不知所措、情绪耗竭和脱离工作。我们的挑战是生产力下降，员工在精神和身体上都精疲力竭，影响了他们的表现。离职率增加，这导致了更高的流失率，给剩余的员工带来了额外的压力，士气低落。员工感到被低估和缺乏支持，造成了消极的工作氛围。好的，在这种情况下你会怎么做？
And again, sadly, this is not unusual. We are seeing more of this. Interestingly, when I did my master's dissertation in 2018, my topic was around wellbeing at work. And at that time, burnout was, I think it was the second or even third reason for long-term sickness absence. Muscular skeletal was absolutely by quite a difference at the top. That has changed in the UK in the last couple of years with burnout now at the top.
同样，可悲的是，这并不罕见。我们看到这种情况越来越多。有趣的是，当我在2018年完成我的硕士论文时，我的主题是关于职场幸福感。在那个时候，倦怠是，我想它是长期病假缺勤的第二甚至第三大原因。肌肉骨骼问题以相当大的差距位居榜首。在过去几年里，这种情况在英国发生了变化，倦怠现在位居榜首。
So there is obviously some things going on, there are things going on that are contributing to that, and this is a reality for people. Just so we're really clear on burnout, when we talk about burnout within work context, it is that it's exhaustion. It's by being exhausted, we're not thinking as well. So cognitive impairment, when I know what I'm like on sleep deprivation,
所以显然有一些事情正在发生，有一些事情正在导致这种情况，这对人们来说是一个现实。为了让我们真正清楚倦怠，当我们谈论工作背景下的倦怠时，它是耗竭。因为精疲力竭，我们思考得不好。所以认知障碍，我知道我在睡眠不足时是什么样子，
emotionally unstable, so emotional impairment. And actually that combination starts to make you withdraw, distance, kind of, you know, we become more cynical, apathetic, that kind of thing. And again, you probably see some of this in your work, but you know, there's some overlaps. And as I said, we're seeing more of it, particularly in roles where there
情绪不稳定，所以情绪障碍。实际上，这种组合开始让你退缩、疏远，你知道，我们变得更加愤世嫉俗、冷漠，诸如此类。同样，你可能在你的工作中也看到过一些这种情况，但你知道，有一些重叠。正如我所说，我们看到的情况越来越多，特别是在那些
are what feels like intolerable demands. I'm really interested in this one today because I was at a fabulous workshop, well, conference last week of a conference like no other. It was in Holland and it was celebrating a theory that we use a lot in workplace wellbeing called the job demands resources theory. It was inspired by Eva Demaruti and built on with her supervisor at the time Wilma, Jofeli, Arnold Backe, these are really big names in organisational psychology. And that theory was developed 25 years ago. So we were at this festival last week celebrating the knowledge that has developed over the last 25 years relating to this theory. And when I talk to people about it, the best way to
感觉需求无法忍受的角色中。我今天对这个特别感兴趣，因为我上周参加了一个很棒的研讨会，好吧，是一个独一无二的会议。它在荷兰，它在庆祝我们在职场幸福感中经常使用的一种理论，称为“工作要求-资源理论”（Job Demands-Resources theory）。它受到Eva Demaruti的启发，并由她当时的导师Wilma Jofeli、Arnold Backe共同建立，这些都是组织心理学界的大人物。该理论是在25年前开发的。所以我们上周在那个节日庆祝过去25年里围绕该理论发展的知识。当我向人们介绍它时，最好的方式是
describe it is imagine you've got a set of of weighing scales and you've got all of your job demands weighing you down on one side, workload, pressure, you know, colleagues, all that kind of thing, relationships if they're not going well, although these are all demands. And then the other side, you've got your resources and the idea, so when we have good relationships with our colleagues, we've got support from our line managers, leaders, all that enriching stuff, the idea is if we've got it in equilibrium, we're going to be feeling okay. If the demands are just completely outweighing the resources available, we're going to be on that one-way ticket to burnout. Interestingly, if we've got too many resources and they're outweighing the
描述它，想象你有一套秤，你所有的工作要求都在一边压着你，工作量、压力、你知道，同事，所有这些事情，如果关系处理得不好，尽管这些都是要求。然后在另一边，你有你的资源，这个想法是，当我们与同事有良好的关系，我们有来自直线经理、领导者的支持，所有那些丰富的东西，这个想法是，如果我们让它处于平衡状态，我们就会感觉还好。如果要求完全超过了可用的资源，我们就会走上倦怠的单程票。有趣的是，如果我们有太多的资源，而它们超过了
demand, that's when we actually get a bit bored. So there is a balance to achieve. So that's a really good theory to try and draw on, to so often use that to try and understand, you know, what are people's demands and what are the resources and is there a misbalance here. What was also really inspiring and I can't give too much on this because I haven't done enough analysis of it since last week but so Wilma Shafeli who decades and decades of experience in stress and burnout at work has recently created a new diagnostic for measuring burnout. It's called the Burnout Assess... I think it's short for BAT, so Burnout Assessment Tool. So that's a new diagnostic that actually, again, recognising that the original burnout instrument was developed decades ago. There's some limitations to it. So there's a new burnout assessment tool that I would certainly look to use as part of the information gathering. I draw on the job designs to try
需求，那才是我们真正感到有点无聊的时候。所以有一个平衡需要实现。所以这是一个非常好的理论，可以尝试利用它来尝试理解，你知道，人们的需求是什么，资源是什么，这里是否存在失衡。同样令人鼓舞的是，我不能透露太多，因为自上周以来我还没有做足够的分析，但Wilma Shafeli在职场压力和倦怠方面拥有几十年的经验，最近创建了一种测量倦怠的新诊断工具。它被称为“倦怠评估工具”（Burnout Assessment Tool，简称BAT）。所以这是一种新的诊断工具，实际上，再次认识到最初的倦怠工具是几十年前开发的。它有一些局限性。所以有一个新的倦怠评估工具，我肯定会考虑将其作为信息收集的一部分。我利用工作设计来尝试
and get to what's going on here, then start to do qualitative interviews, try and find out what was driving the excessive demands potentially. And once we kind of have that information, then it's about trying to design interventions. And when it comes to well-being interventions I would always take the participation route for well-being interventions. People who work in the organization know what they need. So getting them and there was another brilliant psychologist who I'm sadly is no longer with us, Corinna Nielsen from Sheffield University, who did brilliant work around wellbeing interventions using participative techniques, getting people on board.
弄清楚这里发生了什么，然后开始进行定性访谈，试图找出是什么导致了潜在的过度需求。一旦我们有了这些信息，就是尝试设计干预措施。当涉及到幸福感干预时，我总是会采取参与式路线。在组织中工作的人知道他们需要什么。所以让他们参与进来，还有另一位出色的心理学家，不幸的是她已经不在我们身边了，谢菲尔德大学的Corinna Nielsen，她在利用参与式技术进行幸福感干预方面做了出色的工作，让人们加入。
So that would be something I would also definitely advocate. And then start to look at some of the job design. So again, another academic hero for me is Sharon Parker. Her work on proactive behavior is one of my inspirations, but she's also done a lot of work in work design and has a really great framework called the Smart Work Design and it really brings in how are we making creating healthy sustainable jobs. So that these are just some of the things I tap into. Amazing and you know it's really lovely
所以这也会是我绝对会提倡的事情。然后开始研究一些工作设计。所以，再次强调，我的另一个学术英雄是Sharon Parker。她在主动行为方面的工作是我的灵感来源之一，但她也在工作设计方面做了很多工作，并有一个非常棒的框架，称为“智能工作设计”（Smart Work Design），它真正引入了我们如何创造健康、可持续的工作。所以这些只是我利用的一些东西。太棒了，你知道，听到那些激励你的人真的很棒。
to hear about the people that inspired you. But let's not forget that for many people, Dr. Joe Gray was going to be, is going to be a real inspiration, you know, and the first occupational and organisational psychologist they will have heard of might well have been from this podcast. It might be this one they're watching right now. And there might be organisations themselves watching this thinking why do we need an organisational psychologist and you're demonstrating beautifully why they need that occupational or organisational psychologist. So I think you are certainly one to watch as well, Jo. Before we think about exactly why with your book that's coming out, shall we have a look at our third case study?
但别忘了，对许多人来说，乔·格雷博士将是，也将是一个真正的灵感来源，你知道，他们听说过的第一位职业和组织心理学家可能就是通过这个播客。他们现在观看的可能就是这一集。可能有一些组织本身在观看这个节目，思考为什么我们需要一位组织心理学家，而你正在完美地展示为什么他们需要那位职业或组织心理学家。所以我认为你当然也是值得关注的人，乔。在我们思考你的新书即将出版的具体原因之前，我们要不要看看我们的第三个案例研究？
Yeah! So supporting organisations to promote a speak up culture. What's the context? The leadership team in a mid-sized software development company known for its cutting-edge products has noticed that employees are increasingly reluctant to speak up in meetings, share ideas or raise concerns. Leadership has observed that innovation and problem solving have slowed and there's growing frustration among managers who feel disconnected from their teams. What are the challenges? We've got disengagement among employees leading to a lack of accountability and impacting on team dynamics
好的！所以支持组织促进“敢言文化”（speak up culture）。背景是什么？一家中型软件开发公司以其尖端产品而闻名，其领导团队注意到员工越来越不愿意在会议上发言、分享想法或提出担忧。领导层观察到创新和解决问题的速度已经放缓，经理们感到与团队脱节，这导致了越来越多的挫败感。挑战是什么？我们有员工的脱离，导致缺乏责任感，并影响团队动态，
and the organization is at risk of losing its competitive edge and impact on future sustainability. Okay Jo, this last one is over to you. And this one really speaks to my area of expertise, proactive behavior at work. So speaking up is what we describe as a proactive behaviour, proactive behaviour self-initiated in order to change the current situation or the environment. So if you think about speaking up, I'm speaking up because I want something to change. Or if we're speaking up and it's around innovation, I'm speaking up because I want to create something. So that idea of creating a speak up culture, it can be to highlight kind of issues within an organization.
而且组织面临失去竞争优势和影响未来可持续性的风险。好的，乔，最后这个交给你了。这一个真正触及了我的专业领域，职场主动行为。所以“敢言”是我们所描述的一种主动行为，主动行为是自我发起的，目的是改变当前的情况或环境。所以如果你考虑敢言，我敢言是因为我想改变某些事情。或者如果我们敢言，并且它是围绕创新的，我敢言是因为我想创造某些东西。所以那种创造敢言文化的想法，它可以是为了突出组织内的问题。
You might speak up if there's some bad behavior being experienced, that's one form of speaking up. But speaking up around improvement ideas, innovation, all that kind of thing, that's also a speaking up type of behaviour. So speaking up comes in various different guises. And I guess it's important if you're, you know, because again, you know, a lot of buzzwords about, oh yeah, we want to create a speak up culture.
如果你经历了一些不良行为，你可能会敢言，这是敢言的一种形式。但围绕改进想法、创新等方面的敢言，那也是一种敢言类型的行为。所以敢言有各种不同的表现形式。而且我想如果你是，你知道，因为再次强调，你知道，有很多关于“哦，是的，我们想创造一种敢言文化”的流行语。
Be really clear. What is it? Why is that important? And why are you trying to do it? And if you are trying to create a speak up culture, then you absolutely need to make sure that the environment is safe for people to speak up. So this really does speak to a lot of my own work. So a bit of some shameless plugging here. But so one of the things I have designed, so I've got a new website, which is called poweringproactivity.com, and I've created what's called the Proactivity Pulse. And that is a short diagnostic that asks questions to almost determine which proactive behaviors
要非常清楚。它是什么？为什么它很重要？你为什么要尝试这样做？如果你正在尝试创造一种敢言文化，那么你绝对需要确保环境对人们来说是安全的，可以让他们敢言。所以这确实触及了我自己的很多工作。所以这里做一点无耻的宣传。但我设计了一些东西，所以我有一个新网站，叫poweringproactivity.com，我创建了所谓的“主动性脉搏”（Proactivity Pulse）。这是一个简短的诊断工具，通过提问来确定哪些主动行为
are in evidence or not within your organization. And there's kind of six key proactive behaviors that I've identified that organizations tend to appreciate value, speaking up will be one of them. So I would probably be asking some of those questions from the speaker, you know, I probably to be fair, I probably asked someone to do the whole pulse. And I've designed it in a way that actually you could get a whole team to do it. And then I can aggregate and, you know, come back with a scores for the whole
在你的组织中是显而易见的，哪些不是。我确定了六种关键的主动行为，组织往往会欣赏和重视，敢言就是其中之一。所以我可能会问一些来自敢言者的问题，你知道，我可能，公平地说，我可能会要求某人完成整个脉搏测试。而且我设计它的方式是，实际上你可以让整个团队都来做。然后我可以汇总，你知道，并返回整个
organisation. So there's, there's that option. And that would then pinpoint, yeah, okay, actually it's speaking up maybe and innovative behaviour. What, what sort of causing that? So once we've got the diagnosis, then it's trying to understand what might be driving it. And that's where my book is premised on the proactive work design framework. So it's a nine dimensional model using the word proactive, and there are nine factors to consider. And the idea is that if you get those nine, if you based on the evidence that's out there, if you are doing those nine things, the chances are you're going to have a pretty empowered workforce.
组织的分数。所以，有那个选项。那将指出，是的，好的，实际上是敢言，也许还有创新行为。什么，什么导致了这种情况？所以一旦我们有了诊断，就是尝试理解是什么在驱动它。这就是我的书以“主动工作设计框架”（proactive work design framework）为前提的原因。所以它是一个九维模型，使用“主动”（proactive）这个词，有九个因素需要考虑。这个想法是，如果你得到那九个，如果你基于现有的证据，如果你正在做那九件事，很有可能你将拥有一支相当赋权的员工队伍。
But if some of those are lacking, then it can have a real impact on certain proactive behaviours. So if people do not feel safe to speak up, guess what? They're going to be silent. So imagine you've probably heard there's quite a lot of psychological safety gets banded around quite a bit. Again, if you're on LinkedIn, quite often, this idea of psychological safety, and it really is premised on the idea that the environment feels safe for people that they're not going to get, you know, told off or shut down or, you know, reprimanded. You see that in, you know, when they have wellbeing, employee surveys, don't they? And even in the NHS every year, there'll be a satisfaction survey. But then
但如果其中一些缺失，那么它会对某些主动行为产生真正的影响。所以如果人们觉得敢言不安全，猜猜怎么着？他们会保持沉默。所以想象一下，你可能听说过，心理安全感被提及得相当多。再次强调，如果你在LinkedIn上，通常情况下，这种心理安全感的想法，它确实是以环境对人们来说感觉安全为前提的，他们不会被，你知道，责骂或关闭，或者，你知道，受到训斥。你在，你知道，当他们有幸福感、员工调查时会看到这一点，不是吗？甚至在NHS每年，都会有满意度调查。但随后
there'll also be the meme of people being escorted out by security for really sharing what they think. And so it's exactly like you say, it doesn't feel psychologically safe to actually be honest about what it's like to work there. I think and I think, you know, there's a psychological safety and that's, and are people going to do something with that? Because sometimes, you know, I speak up, I'm not being heard. So, you know, there's also the idea of how we can kind of create influence, you know, help people to develop the skill to be able to be heard in a way that influences others and allows them to be heard. So yes, there's a few chapters in the book that I would say are very much linked to speaking up. But the idea and the way the book is premised is that you do that diagnostic.
还会有一种模因，就是人们因为真正分享了自己的想法而被保安护送出去。所以正如你所说，在那种环境下，坦诚地表达工作感受在心理上并不安全。我认为，心理安全感是存在的，但人们会利用它做些什么吗？因为有时我表达了意见，却没人听。所以，关于我们如何建立影响力，帮助人们培养能够以影响他人并让自己被倾听的方式进行沟通的技能，这也是一个值得探讨的想法。所以是的，书中有几个章节我认为与“敢于发声”密切相关。但这本书的理念和前提是，你需要先进行诊断。
And the things that you're already doing well, great. Don't worry too much about those. Let's try and work on the areas that probably need a little bit of attention. The other thing I have also recently worked on is I've created a kind of coaching framework around how to build confidence in speaking up. And I've used again, sorry, I'm a bit overuse of acronyms but it's called the safe framework and the S is for psychological safety so a little bit of a stretch PS but psychological safety, authenticity,
对于你已经做得很好的事情，很好，不用太担心。让我们试着去改善那些可能需要多加关注的领域。我最近还致力于创建了一个关于如何建立发声自信的辅导框架。我再次使用了缩写，抱歉，我有点过度使用缩写了，但它被称为“SAFE”框架。S代表心理安全感（Psychological Safety），虽然缩写有点牵强，但确实是心理安全感，还有真实性（Authenticity），
fairness and emotions and the idea there is one we need to be psychologically safe, like I just explained. But also to speak up, you need to feel authentic. You need to feel like you can be authentic. And again, sometimes in organizations, there are social norms, expectations, and people don't feel like they can be authentic. You need to feel authentic and true to your values to be able to speak up on things that are important to you. So it's the authenticity piece is about helping individuals build confidence to be true to themselves. So that's the kind of authenticity one. The fairness considerations, a lot of people speak up when things are unfair. Some of us have higher fairness barometers than
公平性（Fairness）和情绪（Emotions）。其核心理念是：首先，我们需要心理安全感，就像我刚才解释的那样。其次，要敢于发声，你需要感到真实。你需要感觉自己可以展现真实的一面。同样，在组织中，有时存在社会规范和期望，人们觉得无法展现真实的自我。你需要感到真实并忠于自己的价值观，才能对重要的事情发表意见。所以，“真实性”部分是关于帮助个人建立自信，从而忠于自我。这就是关于真实性的部分。至于公平性考量，很多人在事情不公平时会发声。我们有些人对公平的衡量标准比
others, but most people will respond when they see something that's unfair. So it's about bringing to their attention. If this feels unfair, how can you therefore communicate that in a way that's authentic to you, that people will be willing to listen to. And then the last one is recognising that sometimes our emotions can get in the way of being heard. So how can we bring some kind of emotional regulation so that again we can be heard without people kind of, you know, dismissing us. So those are like techniques that you can coach someone to help build those areas of strength to give them the power to and confidence to speak up.
其他人更高，但大多数人在看到不公平的事情时都会做出反应。所以关键在于引起他们的注意。如果这让你感到不公平，你该如何以一种真实的方式将其传达出来，让人们愿意倾听呢？最后一点是认识到，有时我们的情绪会阻碍我们被倾听。所以，我们如何进行某种情绪调节，以便我们能被倾听，而不至于被他人忽视。这些都是你可以用来辅导他人的技巧，帮助他们建立这些优势领域，赋予他们发声的力量和自信。
Amazing. And I do, I love all your acronyms. I love them. And it makes them, yeah, it makes them easier to remember, doesn't it? But also to kind of use to implement because you kind of can stick them up and then they catch you out. And I should, yeah, you do that. I
太棒了。我真的很喜欢你所有的缩写。我太喜欢了。这让它们更容易记住，不是吗？而且也更容易应用，因为你可以把它们贴出来，它们会提醒你。我应该，是的，你确实应该这样做。我
should do that. Use that. And I liked that you had your own five five P's model as well, because that's like a CBT thing, isn't it? But now obviously is a is an occupational psychologist thing as well. So we are sold on this as being really helpful. We are sold on you. And so we should be definitely checking out your brand new book, baby, shouldn't we, Jo? Tell us about your new book. So I've obviously been alluding to it already. So it's called Powering Workplace Proactivity, How to Create a future focus change oriented culture.
应该这样做。使用它。我很喜欢你也有自己的“5P”模型，因为那就像是认知行为疗法（CBT）的东西，对吧？但现在显然它也是职业心理学的东西。所以我们都认为这非常有帮助。我们都被你说服了。所以我们绝对应该去看看你的新书，对吧，Jo？给我们介绍一下你的新书吧。我显然已经提到过它了。它叫《赋能职场主动性：如何创造以未来为导向、以变革为核心的文化》（Powering Workplace Proactivity, How to Create a future focus change oriented culture）。
And it's recognising that proactive behaviours can be really helpful for organisations, but individuals may not always feel that the environment within their organisation is enabling or stimulating that behaviour. So I'm a big advocate of this kind of fix the environment before you try to fix the person. I think sometimes within psychology generally, we have a tendency to want to fix the person first and foremost.
它认识到主动行为对组织非常有益，但个人可能并不总是觉得组织内的环境能够促进或激发这种行为。所以我非常主张“在试图改变人之前先改善环境”。我认为在心理学领域，我们通常倾向于首先想要改变人。
And I think actually if the environment is right, then actually that might enable the person to thrive. They don't need fixing. So this idea of let's fix the environment first. And then if there's still, you know, there will still be individuals who for one reason or another lack confidence, lack, you know, the self-esteem and self-efficacy, you need to be proactive and, you know, might need a bit more hand holding. But let's just get the environment right first. And so that is what the book is about,
我认为实际上如果环境合适，那么个人可能就会茁壮成长。他们不需要被“修复”。所以这个理念是：让我们先改善环境。当然，仍然会有一些人因为各种原因缺乏自信、缺乏自尊和自我效能感，需要更多的引导。但让我们先搞好环境。这就是这本书的主题，
creating the environment, the culture, before we start just fixing people. And that really made me think about comparing and contrasting, for example, the NHS versus YouTube and Google as an employer. So I went to the YouTube offices earlier this year. And they have a free canteen, you might know this already, Joe, but they have a free canteen that's like buffet, amazing salads, soups, you know, kind of little Brazilian tapas and burgers and fresh
在开始“修复”人之前，先创造环境和文化。这真的让我想到了对比，例如英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）与YouTube和谷歌作为雇主的区别。今年早些时候我去了YouTube的办公室。他们有免费的食堂，你可能已经知道了，Jo，他们的食堂就像自助餐，有很棒的沙拉、汤，还有巴西小吃、汉堡和新鲜的
pastas and deliciousness. All the drinks, you drinks, all the puddings, all of that. And it's free for all employees if they're on site that day. They also have a rooftop terrace with barista made coffees with an ice cream fridge, all of that's free. You get access to the gym there. You also get massage credits that you get to use. You get so many massage credits a year. and then you can also buy extra massages. And I just think, you know what, that's a pretty cool culture.
意大利面，非常美味。所有的饮料、甜点，应有尽有。如果员工当天在现场，这些都是免费的。他们还有一个屋顶露台，有咖啡师制作的咖啡，还有一个冰淇淋冰箱，所有这些都是免费的。你可以使用健身房，还可以获得按摩积分，每年都有一定数量的按摩积分，你还可以购买额外的按摩服务。我只是觉得，你知道吗，这是一种非常酷的文化。
Obviously, people will still choose to leave at some point in the future, of course, but I think it's about, for me, valuing your employees, you know, whereas when I was in the NHS, I once got a pair of fluffy socks as my Christmas bonus with one chocolate gold coin. And I actually said at the time, I would have rather had the two pounds it cost them to buy. And had they consulted us on what we wanted on our bonus, I don't think anybody would have said I'd like a pair of fluffy socks and a chocolate coin. So I
当然，人们在未来某个时候还是会选择离开，但我认为对我来说，这关乎于重视你的员工。而当我在NHS工作时，我的圣诞奖金是一双毛绒袜子和一个巧克力金币。我当时就说，我宁愿要那两英镑的成本费。如果他们就奖金问题征求过我们的意见，我不认为有人会说想要一双毛绒袜子和一个巧克力金币。所以我
think, you know, I know that Google and NHS are not really comparable as an organisation. But, you know, it just that's what resonated with me when I heard you say what you said. Yeah. And I think, you know, it's also about the job design, you know, so the, you know, the perks around the edges, lovely, but it's about giving people opportunities to have meaningful work, regardless of what that role is. But, you know, they do feel that they're being heard and I'm contributing. So when we talk to people around, when they feel empowered, when they're being proactive, and it's wanted and valued, then they are, you know, pride, joy, energize. So we actually creating, you know, on that scales, I talked about earlier, yeah, proactive behavior, when welcomed can be a
认为，我知道谷歌和NHS作为组织并不具备可比性。但是，当你刚才说那些话时，我产生了共鸣。是的，我认为这还关乎工作设计。边缘福利固然很好，但关键在于让人们有机会从事有意义的工作，无论职位是什么。他们确实感到自己被倾听，并且在做出贡献。所以当我们谈论人们感到被赋能、表现出主动性，且这种主动性受到欢迎和重视时，他们会感到自豪、快乐和充满活力。所以我们实际上是在创造……正如我之前提到的，主动行为在受到欢迎时可以是一种
resource, can also be a demand. Because if we're in an environment, where it's not welcome, and I'm pushing, it's like I'm hitting brick wall every time I come up with something, that becomes a demand. And that can actually lead people to burn out and leave. So there's a double edged, proactivity itself is double edged,
资源，但也可能是一种负担。因为如果我们处于一个不欢迎主动性的环境中，而我还在推动，就像每次提出建议都撞上南墙一样，这就会变成一种负担。这实际上会导致人们精疲力竭并选择离开。所以主动性本身是一把双刃剑，
but when the environment is right for it and individuals can exercise it, that's when the magic happens. So that's kind of what I, that's what I want to do. I want to create workplaces where people feel they can go to work, contribute, feel like they're having it, you know, meaningful experiences, and someone's valuing it. And as a result, the organization's doing well. That's, that's my aim. You're all thriving together. You know, you're earning money in a way that feels like it's authentic
但当环境合适且个人能够发挥主动性时，奇迹就会发生。这就是我想做的。我想创造这样的工作场所：人们觉得他们可以去工作、做出贡献、获得有意义的体验，并且有人重视这些。结果就是组织发展得很好。这就是我的目标。你们都在共同成长。你们以一种感觉真实的方式赚钱，
to you, makes you feel good. You've got joy in delivering that service that makes it feel like what you are delivering is being appreciated by everyone, by the clients, but also by the people around you. They're not undermining you. They're not jealous of you. They're not sniping at you. It actually feels like a joy to come to work and that is not impossible, it is possible for that to be the case and not just in a self-employed situation, that's not the only environment where you can love your job. Yes absolutely, 100%. Amazing. So who is the ideal client for your book, do you think, Jo? So, if you're a HR professional, for sure, if you're involved, anyone, HR professional, organisational development consultants, anyone who's in an organisation
让你感觉良好。你在提供服务时感到快乐，让你觉得你所交付的成果得到了每个人的赞赏，包括客户，也包括你周围的人。他们不会破坏你，不会嫉妒你，也不会在背后说你坏话。去上班实际上是一种快乐，这并非不可能，这种情况是完全可能的，而且不仅仅是在自雇的情况下，那并不是唯一能让你热爱工作的地方。是的，绝对，百分之百。太棒了。那么你认为谁是你这本书的理想读者呢，Jo？如果你是人力资源专业人士，当然，如果你参与其中，任何人力资源专业人士、组织发展顾问，任何在组织中
and has an influence over how work is designed and the organization is designed. Leaders at any level, managers, anyone who has an influence in creating the culture, so do individuals, but it is leaders, managers, even coaches, because quite a lot of the interventions, so within the book I've got some little tools and some resources, and there are some coaching interventions so actually even if you are a coach who's interested in helping people and organizations leaders create those environments then it could also be helpful for them. Perfect and we are releasing this episode at the point where this is a brand new book baby you can go out and buy this now. Is Amazon the best place to go? Is it available in other places too?
并且对工作设计和组织设计有影响力的人。任何级别的领导者、经理，任何在创造文化方面有影响力的人，个人也可以，但主要是领导者、经理，甚至是教练。因为书中有许多干预措施，我提供了一些小工具和资源，还有一些教练干预方法，所以即使你是一位有兴趣帮助个人和组织领导者创造这些环境的教练，这本书对他们也会很有帮助。太完美了。我们发布这一集时，这本书刚刚上市，大家现在就可以去购买了。亚马逊是最好的购买渠道吗？其他地方有售吗？
It's available in all good outlets. If you go to my website, powerinproactivity.com, for a limited time there is a discount code that you can use at Routledge. So the publishers are Routledge. So Routledge.com, you can go there. And if you want to benefit from the discount code, go via my website. It's on Amazon, it's in Waterstones, and hopefully other reputable book outlets. Lovely. Thank you so much, Jo. And I believe that code is currently available until the end of June 2025. but there might well be future discount codes available. So please do go and check out Jo's website.
它在所有好的销售渠道都有售。如果你访问我的网站 powerinproactivity.com，在有限的时间内，你可以使用 Routledge 的折扣码。出版商是 Routledge。所以你可以去 Routledge.com。如果你想享受折扣，请通过我的网站。它在亚马逊、Waterstones 有售，希望其他信誉良好的书店也有。
Jo, where's the best place for people to be able to connect with you, follow you, engage with your work? So LinkedIn, I would say, although I have got an Instagram page for Powering Proactivity, so you can find me on LinkedIn, Jo Gray, Instagram page for Powering Proactivity. So you can find me on LinkedIn, Joe Gray. But there's also Powering Proactivity has a LinkedIn page and a Instagram page. So yeah, you can you will find me one confusing thing is on the book. It's Joanne Gray. I to friends on Joe Gray with an E. I know that's confusing. But so if you can't find me, is your man great? It might be Joe great or vice versa.
太好了。非常感谢你，Jo。我相信该代码目前有效期至 2025 年 6 月底，但未来可能会有新的折扣码。所以请务必去看看 Jo 的网站。Jo，人们联系你、关注你、参与你的工作最好的方式是什么？LinkedIn，我会说是 LinkedIn，虽然我也有一个名为“Powering Proactivity”的 Instagram 页面，所以你可以在 LinkedIn 上找到我，Jo Gray。但“Powering Proactivity”也有一个 LinkedIn 页面和一个 Instagram 页面。所以是的，你会找到我的。有一点令人困惑的是，书上写的是 Joanne Gray。朋友们叫我 Jo Gray（带 E）。我知道这很令人困惑。所以如果你找不到我，可能是 Joanne Gray，也可能是 Jo Gray，反之亦然。
Joe, thank you so much for your time today and coming back to speak with us. Wishing you the very best of luck with your brand new book, baby. Please do stay in contact and hope it really soars for you. Thank you so much. And thanks for having me. It's been a joy and pleasure. Oh, it really has been. Hope you have a lovely rest of your day. Thank you, Jo. Thank you. Oh, what an absolute treat it was to speak to Jo. Please, if you do think that you would find her work interesting, please do buy her brand new book, which is available right now.
Jo，非常感谢你今天抽出时间回来与我们交谈。祝你的新书大卖。请保持联系，希望它能为你带来巨大的成功。非常感谢。也谢谢你邀请我。这真是一次愉快而美妙的经历。哦，确实如此。希望你余下的时间过得愉快。谢谢你，Jo。谢谢。哦，与 Jo 的交谈真是一种享受。如果你觉得她的作品很有趣，请务必购买她的新书，现在就可以买到。
There will be details in the show notes and in the description for this video, if you're watching on YouTube. I love it when you tell me how helpful this content is. If there are past episodes that you would like to see broadened or delved into in more depth, please do let me know. Reach out to me on my social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent Everywhere. Drop me a comment or a question on any YouTube video. If you're listening on Spotify, you can do Q&A questions on there too. If you find the content helpful, you can rate and review on Apple podcast, please do. And wherever you listen to
节目说明和视频描述中会有详细信息，如果你是在 YouTube 上观看的话。我很喜欢你们告诉我这些内容有多么有帮助。如果有过去的内容你希望看到扩展或深入探讨，请务必告诉我。在我的社交媒体上联系我，我到处都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。在任何 YouTube 视频下给我留言或提问。如果你在 Spotify 上收听，也可以在那里进行问答。如果你觉得内容有帮助，请在 Apple Podcast 上评分和评论，拜托了。无论你在哪里收听
your podcast, please do follow the show. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster or creator. If you love conversations about psychology, please do come and join my free psychology group on Facebook, which is called the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And there's a new video every week on Fridays at around 9am, which is called Marianne's Motivation and Mindset. You can also grab your free psychology success guide by going along to my website, www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk qualified as the aspiring psychologist part. My name is Diakolo La Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist.
你的播客，请务必关注这个节目。这对任何播客或创作者来说都是最友好的支持。如果你喜欢关于心理学的对话，请加入我在 Facebook 上的免费心理学小组，名字叫“Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent”。每周五上午 9 点左右会有一个新视频，叫“Marianne's Motivation and Mindset”。你也可以访问我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk 获取免费的心理学成功指南。我是 Diakolo La Amujo，一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。
Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK decline site application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trainee clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favourite part of the book as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Marion 博士的书《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中非常有帮助。由于我计划在英国继续研究生学习，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家和实习生的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。